à 15000 km d'ici Caroline côté vient de
réaliser un rêve et une performance hors
du commun pour parcourir seul en ski de
fond avec un traîneau d'une cinquantaine
de kilos 1130 km jusqu'au point le plus
au sud de notre planète elle a mis 34
jours 2 heures et 53 minutes c'est 4
jours de moins que le précédent record
c'est courir 1 à 2 marathons par jour
pendant 34 jours Frédéric Dion en sait
quelque chose lui qui a aussi traversé
l'Antarctique tracté par un cerf volant
en 2014 sur 55 jours d'expédition j'ai
fait 9 jours seulement de
tirage de traîneau comme ça sans levant
mais juste assez pour imaginer l'effort
aucune image de son exploit n'est pour
l'instant disponible Caroline côté les
rapports avec elle pour raconter les
températures autour de -35 les vents et
les jours de brouillard blanc où l'on ne
distingue plus le ciel du sol c'est
important pour moi essayé d'emmener le
plus de gens possible en nature Caroline
côté est une ultra marathonienne et une
habituée des expéditions dans des
régions aussi hostiles que fascinantes
comme ici dans le Svalbard un décor qui
n'a rien à envier aux productions
hollywoodiennes à part les conditions de
tournage
lui c'est son partenaire d'aventure
d'habitude et son partenaire tout court
être totalement seul pendant une telle
traversée c'est l'un des plus grands
défis se rappelle la rameuse mylène
Paquette on est une personne seule dans
un environnement peu accueillant assez
hostile et on est seul mais c'est
l'équipe c'est le facteur humain qui
soutient nos faits et gestes qui nous
motive à aller de l'avant d'ailleurs
amis parcours après avoir enchaîné 30 à
40 km par jour Caroline côté reçoit une
dose de motivation supplémentaire son
mari l'attendra à la station au pôle Sud
je devrais y arriver
il lui restait encore de longs jours
sans nuit avant de mettre un point final
à son exploit ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal